Sometimes you just need a few extra seconds
before all the screaming and stabbing starts
up again.
From nightmarish jump scares to unbelievably
weird-looking beasts, these are the most paused
horror movie moments.
David Kessler is having a rough vacation.
He just wanted to go backpacking across the
Yorkshire moors, but the moment he steps off
the beaten path, he's attacked by a werewolf.
When he wakes up in a London hospital, he
keeps having ghastly nightmares.
These freaky dreams are the scariest parts
of An American Werewolf in London.
From the hospital, we cut to David's home.
He's working on his college homework, his
family is watching TV, and everything seems
peaceful.
Before we can get our bearings, an army of
mutant Nazi monsters bursts into the house
and guns down David's family.
They burn his home, shoot everything to pieces,
and kill David.
And that's when our hero wakes up in his hospital
bed.
It was all just a nasty Nazi dream, and his
sympathetic nurse is only too happy to open
up the curtains and let some sunlight in.
But as she pulls back the shades, there's
a Nazi-Beast standing there, knife in hand,
and he stabs the nurse to death.
We haven't even seen the American werewolf
yet, and we're already pressing pause so we
can collect our nerves.
The psycho witch turned evil spirit, Bathsheba
is having a great time in The Conjuring, terrorizing
the poor Perron family.
Of course, if those kids think they're scared
whenever Bathsheba shows up, then they've
got no idea what we're going through.
Whether she's playing "hide and clap" in the
cellar or getting all possessive, every time
this hag shows up on screen, we're hiding
behind the sofa.
Of course, there's one Bathsheba scene that
stands head and shoulders above the rest.
It's the scene where young Andrea hears something
banging around inside her wardrobe.
Nervous, she goes to check it out, flings
open the doors, and finds nothing inside.
That's because Bathsheba is up on top, just
waiting to pounce.
Horror fans will want to press the pause button
here for multiple reasons.
One, it's our first good look at the demon
haunting the Perron family, and she is a terrifying
sight to behold.
Secondly, this is one of the scariest scenes
in movie history, and when your heart rate
spikes to new and dangerous levels, you'll
need to take a break and remind yourself it's
just a movie.
Wes Craven and Sam Raimi are masters of the
horror genre, and their films have a combined
body count higher than most serial killers.
In addition to giving us some of the scariest
movies ever made, Craven and Raimi also had
a friendly feud going on, where they'd reference
each other's movies in their own films.
For example, in the first Evil Dead, a slashed-up
movie poster for The Hills Have Eyes makes
an appearance.
Craven returned the favor in A Nightmare on
Elm Street when Nancy Thompson falls asleep
watching Evil Dead.
Raimi's well-loved film makes another appearance
in the Craven-directed Scream, when one character
considers watching the undead action flick
before deciding against it.
"How many Evil Dead?
How many Hellraiser?"
As for Raimi, he absolutely loves putting
Freddy Krueger's glove into his deadite franchise.
Not only did it show up in an episode of Ash
vs. Evil Dead, but the deadly fashion accessory
also appears in Raimi's horror masterpiece,
Evil Dead II.
Eagle-eyed horror fans should press pause
when Ash Williams heads down into the fruit
cellar or walks into the woodshed.
The glove shows up in both scenes, hanging
on the wall in all its razor-bladed glory.
Now we can't stop thinking about that Freddy
vs. Jason vs. Ash movie that we're never going
to get.
The Stephen King bestseller Gerald's Game
seems like an unfilmable book.
The plot follows a woman named Jessie who
retreats to a secluded country house with
her husband Gerald, where they hope to rekindle
their marriage.
Unfortunately, after cuffing his wife to the
bed, Gerald keels over from a heart attack,
leaving his wife handcuffed to the bed alone.
From there, the novel pretty much takes place
inside Jessie's head.
Somehow, director Mike Flanagan and actress
Carla Gugino turned this crazy book into one
of the very best King adaptations.
Of course, that also means they had to shoot
the infamous degloving scene.
"Okay then.
Visualize it then.
All of it."
Now, there are horror moments that make you
scream, and ones that make you want to throw
up.
The degloving scene from Gerald's Game will
make you want to do both at once.
Desperate to get free, especially since a
hungry dog and the creepy Moonlight Man might
return any time, Jessie takes some serious
steps to escape her bonds.
She slits her wrist with a piece of glass
and then she just starts yanking until the
skin on her hand starts peeling off.
She basically turns her hand inside out to
make her great escape.
This gnarly scene sent people into hysterics,
and once it's all over, the pause button will
come in handy as you proceed to lose your
lunch.
It is full of blink-and-you'll-miss-it moments
that require a pause button to fully appreciate,
like the scene when Ben Hanscom spends a day
studying at the library.
Unfortunately, things take an unsettling turn
when a librarian shows up.
When she hands Ben a book on local history,
she shames him for staying indoors during
the summer, but Ben just ignores her.
"A boy should be spending his summer with
friends.
Don't you have any friends?"
"Can I have the book now?"
However, reading about Derry isn't a relaxing
way to spend your day.
The town has a haunted history, and Ben is
horrified to learn about a devastating explosion
that decapitated some poor kid and sent his
head hurling into a tree.
The images are upsetting, but the really scary
stuff is happening behind Ben.
After the librarian leaves, another librarian,
who was previously shelving volumes in the
background before the conversation, stops
what she's doing and starts staring at Ben
- just before Pennywise starts appearing in
the book's pages.
Press pause, and you'll see she's grinning
an evil grin and watching like a predator
about to devour its prey.
Obviously, this means that Pennywise is prowling
about, and the longer you look, the more goosebumps
you get.
Mandy is an LSD-infused nightmare, complete
with tigers, chainsaw battles, and a posse
of demon bikers who look like they just rode
out of Hellraiser.
They're known as the Black Skulls, and they
only love two things in this world: drugs
and pain.
There are legends of these guys riding up
and down the interstate, murdering truckers
and hitchhikers, and these creatures share
a weird connection with a psycho cult called
the Children of Dawn.
If these hippies ever need some muscle, they
just blow a magical horn and the demons appear,
ready to ride.
The first time the Black Skulls roll onto
the screen, shrouded by smoke and blood red
light, it's a moment to behold.
Much like the Cenobites, the Black Skulls
each have their own grotesque look.
The design for each biker is so unique that
we've got to press pause and marvel at each
one for just a moment… before they're unleashed
on our poor heroes, and things get gory.
The Perfection follows two cellists who both
attended the same prestigious conservatory.
After meeting for the first time, they go
on a roadtrip across China.
However, icky stuff starts happening the moment
they get on the road.
Current superstar Lizzie comes down with a
mysterious flu, and her new friend and lover
Charlotte does her best to help Lizzie survive
their nightmarish bus trip.
As they wind deeper and deeper into the Chinese
mountains, Lizzie starts throwing up all over
the place.
Puking is bad enough, but when Charlotte takes
a closer look, she sees that Lizzie's vomit
is full of maggots.
Even worse, Lizzie's arm starts wriggling,
like insects are literally crawling under
her skin.
It looks like she's become some sort of bug
incubator, and the insects are going to devour
her arm… until Charlotte pulls a meat cleaver
out of her backpack and tells Lizzie to chop
off a limb.
When Lizzie pulls out that meat cleaver, we've
got to hit pause so we can figure out what
the heck is going on.
But hey, don't worry, things are going to
get way more bizarre before this film is over.
"Should we just get this check and pretend
that none of this ever happened?"
"This is your moment.
You can bow out gracefully and I'll never
hold it against you."
The Ritual follows four friends who head into
the Swedish woods and encounter a pagan cult
that worships an ancient entity.
As it turns out, that entity really loves
skewering people on tree branches.
The monster is called the Jötunn, a beast
out of Norse mythology, and for most of the
film, the giant creature keeps out of sight.
It hides in the forest, plaguing our four
heroes with horrible nightmares before turning
them into shish kebabs.
Eventually, the surviving backpackers are
captured by that aforementioned cult, and
unlucky Dom is offered to the Jötunn as a
sacrifice.
Up until this point, we still haven't seen
the mysterious beast, but when Dom finally
finds himself face-to-face with the oversized
creature, it's unlike anything we've ever
seen before.
The Jötunn has the body of a goat on steroids.
The top half of its head looks like a decapitated
human torso with deer antlers.
Its glowing eyes are buried in a cavern where
its face should be, and there are long human-like
arms hanging off the sides of its head.
It's a truly bizarre creature, and we just
have to press pause and admire its wild design.
Unpopular ending aside, Signs is an entertaining
and terrifying sci-fi flick, and there are
more than a few scenes in this M. Night Shyamalan
film that scared us senseless.
But if we're talking about pause-worthy moments,
we all know exactly what scene is going to
make this list: the Brazilian birthday party.
By this point in the film, it's pretty clear
that aliens are invading Earth.
We've got crop circles, lights in the sky,
and chattering voices on baby monitors.
But other than a quick glimpse of a leg, we
haven't actually seen an alien yet.
That all changes when Merrill turns on the
news.
Not wanting to freak out his family, he moves
the television into a coat closet to follow
the invasion on the news.
When he sees a home video of a close encounter,
Merrill loses his mind.
The footage is shot on a camcorder, lending
a disturbing realism to the scene.
A Brazilian dad is filming his kid's birthday
party, but the children are screaming and
crying because there's something awful outside.
The dad points his camera into an alleyway,
and suddenly, the alien lurches into view.
The long-limbed creature is only onscreen
for a second, but it's enough to send shivers
down our spines.
We're pressing pause as fast we can because
we need to collect ourselves and to get a
better look at this ugly extraterrestrial.
Home invasion movies might be the scariest
sort of horror movie.
After all, while Freddy Krueger won't actually
kill you in your dreams, it's possible that
a trio of real-world mask-wearing psychos
might drop by one night to terrorize you just
because you're home.
That's the premise of The Strangers, a chilling
horror flick where a couple are having one
tough night even before the Strangers arrive.
When her boyfriend runs to the store, Kristen
finds herself home alone and feeling a little
unsettled.
The house is eerily quiet and strangely empty,
and something feels a little off, almost like
Kristen is being watched.
And that's because there's a masked killer
standing in the hallway, just a few feet behind
her.
The villain stands in the door, perfectly
happy to watch Kristen walk around the house,
tracking her as she moves from one side of
the room to the other.
The whole thing is done in one wide shot,
which creates an unbearable sense of anxiety.
The tension is so thick you could cut it with
a knife, and things get so quietly intense
that we can't help but press pause.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.